what is the strangest conspiracy
theories you've come across my absolute
favorite one is I'm not a real person
that I'm actually Jack Black being paid
by the CIA in a disguise Jack
[Music]
Black this is Star Talk Cosmic queries
Edition Neil degrass Tyson here your
personal astrophysicist my co-host for
this episode Paul Muro Paul how you
doing man I'm doing great great to see
you again buddy good to have you back I
and you know every time I take another
look at your resume it's like you're an
Emmy Award winner and Peabody
awardwinning comedian yes I am I mean
this is good stuff and the peab that's
the one you really want there I
everybody's got an ammy but a Peabody
that's the one where people go oh you
read a book
okay so today is a very important topic
something that's centerpiece to so much
of what I do and what I care about it's
anti-science in the medical community
and that is anti-science as expressed by
the public about the medical community
but also forgotten diseases with Peter
Hotes Peter Hotes welcome to Star Talk
uh thank you Neil I'm a huge fan and of
both of you and uh and I'm thrilled to
be here it's uh very exciting for me and
it impressed the heck out of all my
kids that was the most important thing
they're they're the toughest crowd of
all the kids are the toughest if we can
boost the domestic front we're all in on
that so you're a pediatrician uh and
you're Dean the of the national school
of tropical medicine that's actually a
thing that's a place at Bayer College a
professor of Pediatrics and molecular
biology at bayor and you're a fellow in
disease and poverty gosh the James Baker
Institute for public policy Peter you
need to work harder right right I don't
know what's going on with you but if I
were religious I'd have to say God put
you on this Earth to do good okay but
I'm not religious so how I don't know
how to say that then thank
you um you're author of several books
forgotten people forgotten diseases the
neglected tropical diseases and their
impact on global health and environment
that was back in 2008 yeah my kids used
to call it dad's forgotten book on
forgotten
okay but it's gone into the Third
Edition so I I think i' I've proved them
somewhat wrong very good very good and
another one the deadly rise of
anti-science a scientist warning o what
year were did that come out that well
you know i' had written this book
vaccines did not cause Rachel's autism
in 2018 and this newel your daughter
Rachel's your daughter and then the new
one is called The Deadly rise of anti
science it talks about how the
antivaccine movement has transitioned
over to more of a political Enterprise
and so I want to describe that change
excellent and so uh so that's out
already is that correct that's correct
yeah okay so so okay we'll look for that
then thank you and you're you were
interviewed persistently uh as covid was
on covid-19 was on the rise and trying
to educate and try to uh disassemble the
misinformation that was sweeping the
world and especially
misinformation not only regarding the
the virus but the vaccines to prevent it
let's let's back up tell me about
forgotten diseases and why that matters
if they're forgotten and no one thinks
about them they're forgotten they're
still out there we just forgot to think
about them is that it so you know most
of my you know people know me for covid
and we've made two covid vaccine
Technologies reached 100 million people
in India and Indonesia but um our our OG
vaccines our vaccine for parasitic
infections and and that's been my first
Passion is making vaccines for tropical
parasitic infections affecting the
world's poorest people on the African
continent Latin America uh uh in
Southeast Asia so forgotten people
forgotten diseases describes that whole
ecosystem of what I call them the most
important diseases you've never heard of
they're the uh diseases such as human
hookworm infection and schistomiasis and
shagas disease lymphatic fasis and river
blindness they're incredibly common it's
just that they only occur among people
who live in extreme poverty so we've
been one of the things we do here in the
Texas Medical Center is to find a way to
make Innovations for the world's poorest
people that the Pharma companies would
not ordinarily be interested so if these
diseases were hitting Europe and the
United States uh there'd be a trillion
dollars invested in it that's what I
would often think but one of the things
that we're finding now and one of the
reasons we created our national school
of tropical medicine here in the Texas
Medical Center was because of a lot of
21st century forces like global warming
climate change urbanization remaining
poverty we're actually now starting to
see some of those same diseases pop up
here in Texas and the Gulf Coast and as
well as in southern Europe and and
what's interesting Neil is that's one of
the hardest advocacy jobs I've ever had
is getting people to understand that
these tropical diseases are now arising
here on the Gulf Coast and and not
because necessarily of immigration or or
across the southern border as a lot of
people want to say but in fact because
of climate change and because of uh
poverty and urbanization and the way I
illustrate that is we have 10% of the
dogs here in Texas with shagas disease
and and it's not because the dogs are
slipping across the border from El
Salvador right that we we've got
transmission of these diseases here and
we're finding shagas disease
transmission here in the United States
as well as aor and some of the others
but it's it's been a it's get it's very
tough to get people to understand that
that we have an A vulnerability here we
need some kind of a we need some kind of
a reality show kind of like the voice
for these obscure diseases here in
America so that then people become aware
of them through like watching television
or something like that you know oh yeah
tactical measures
there exactly so at the risk of stating
the obvious here what you're saying is
as uh climate warms changes and includes
warm ing trends at latitudes that
previously did not experience such
warming the diseases that previously had
been constrained to the tropics are now
spilling into other latitudes on Earth
presumably north and south and so this
is a
spread that has been empowered by
climate change that's ex well climate
change but one of the things that I
found in my writings and and is that
it's not only not only climate change
it's climate change is working in
concert with other social determinant
such as urbanization that's a big one
right because 80s egypti mosquitoes that
transmit yellow fever or ziko virus
infection or dangi live in the discarded
tires that are in urban neighborhoods so
if you go into poor neighborhoods in and
around Houston where you see all the
tire dumping that's actually a risk
factor um together with wait I do I have
to interject it's not that the
mosquitoes like rubber
okay no it's a very F it's a fascinating
fact I'll I'll explain Paul I don't know
if you knew the shape of a
discarded
tire is ideal to trap water inside of it
no matter how you Orient the tire right
so if if so there's water inside just
sip pooling there if you pick up the
tire and roll it the water just stays in
there if you tip it sideways it curls
around around the edge and pulls at the
bottom so you actually have to like
shake it and and like dehydrate it and
so so so what's weird Peter is that this
could be a major Vector for mosquitoes
just discarded tires that's a weird
crazy fact about so so that little
vignette you just gave is exactly what I
said to our mayor of Houston at the time
a Sylvester Turner extraordinary guy uh
Harvard Harvard log graduate and um
convinced him that we had to get rid of
all the tire dumping in the low-income
neighborhoods in Houston and and so
while South Texas had zika virus
Transmission in 2016 we did not have
that in Houston now whether it was in
spite of what we did or because of it uh
we'll never know I'll take credit for it
anyway but aren't you just transferring
the problem somewhere else and they get
rid of TIR see like when I steal cars
and take the tires I I wondering I was
going to ask you about that I always cut
the tires with a chainsaw and open them
up because I'm concerned about all of
these viruses and
disease that's that's so 20th century I
thought catalytic converters were like
the new thing oh they are thank you very
well I actually have some in the trunk
of my car I can talk to you after the
show about that but I even know what a
catalytic inverter looks like but that's
what I so so tell me now about the rise
of I've known about anti-science outside
of medicine because it's not so much
anti- science but uh pseudoscience that
permeates but if if a person is
susceptible to pseudoscience it seems to
me they'd be susceptible to anti-science
because pseudo science are ways of
thinking that conflict with mainstream
scientific thoughts and understandings
of the world so where did you first see
your medical anti-science well Neil
first of all you've been a role model
over the years for how you com batle and
debunk a lot of the pseudo science so I
often follow your cues and and and you
were actually an inspiration for me to
get involved in this um for which I have
to pay you back somehow no no paid for
now I've become Public Enemy Number One
with it comes with a territory right
well what happened was you know I have
the original assertion against vaccines
Rose in the late 1990s with false claims
that vaccines cause autism and so I have
a four adult kids including Rachel as
autism intellectual disabilities and and
wrote the book vaccines did not cause
Rachel's autism 2018 a deep dive
explaining why there's no link between
vaccines and autism the science behind
it also what autism is how it begins an
early fetal brain development through
the action of autism genes we did HX on
genomic sequencing and Rachel my wife
Ann and I and and laid it all out there
and it was a very powerful book I think
and and and it helped a lot of people
but it also wound up making me Public
Enemy Number one or two with antivaccine
groups Robert F Ken our friend Robert F
Kennedy Jr sted publicly labeled me the
OG villain and I'm so old and square I
had to look up what that means what OG
means yeah Original Gangster villain so
so thanks for inviting the OG villain
and but it was meaning you know I did
find it meaningful and now I realize if
you're in the ve in in trying to make
vaccines for hookworm vaccines and new
covid vaccines like we're doing this is
also part of it now countering the
antivaccine activism the problem was it
took another level I know it actually
started before the covid pandemic but it
really accelerated which became a
political Enterprise linked to political
extremism on the far right and and you
started to see and this is where it gets
really tough because as you know the all
of our training of scientist says we
don't really like to talk about
Republicans and Democrats and liberals
or conservatives or red States or blue
States but what do you do when um the
people refusing vaccines overwhelmingly
are in red States and the study showed
from Charles Gaba and others that the
redder the county the lower the
immunization rate and higher the death
rate so much so that David leonhard of
the New York Times just called it red Co
and and it and it's a killing Force so
so 40,000 Texans in my state of Texans
died because they refused a covid
vaccine during the Delta and ba1 wave
after vaccines were widely available and
200,000 Americans overall and and that's
why we have to talk about it because
anti-science is no longer just kind of
this theoretical thing it's actually
politically not small numbers but we can
separate the variables as we say in
mathematics my understanding was and we
explored this in the film
shot in the arm this is written and
directed by um Scott Hamilton Kennedy is
a documentarian you were prominently
interviewed in that film I I served as a
as script consultant because there's a
lot of science getting communicated and
I advised on that and then I got like
promoted to Executive Producer last time
I agree to that that was the whole thing
but anyhow in that we explored the fact
that they're two separate variables here
one of them is are you anti-science
because you hate big Pharma or whatever
and another one is you can't make me get
a vaccine because I'm American and I'm
free and freedom and so one came from
the right from the left the other came
from the right and they met on the other
side of the fence because they both had
the same
objective so are you I presume you've
seen both of these camps right and they
they require different solutions even
though their goals are the same it's
changed over time you know we used to
say the antivaccine movement was a
product of the as you rightly point out
the extreme left and the ex extreme
right there on the extreme right it was
Health Freedom medical Freedom you can't
tell me what to do on the extreme left
it was you know a piece love granola we
have to be you know careful what we're
putting into our kids and and and eat
your herbs and that'll cure your and the
stuff on the left has somewhat
dissipated not entirely because you
still see a lot of people pedling
nutritional supplements you know linked
to the antivaccine movement but it's
mostly the The Killing Force the one
that killed 200,000 Americans
overwhelmingly is a product now of the
far right so you've got and it's tough
to talk about you've got members of the
House Freedom caucus you know calling
people like me medical Brown Shirts
that's the term they use I'm using Nazi
analogies pretty horrible stuff and and
you've got you know two US senators Ron
Johnson Wisconsin holding vaccine injury
roundtables and Senator Ram Paul
targeting Science And scientists you had
the CPAC Conference of conservatives
first they're going to vaccinate you
then they're going to take away your
guns and your Bibles and it's ridiculous
that sounds to us people accepted it in
my state of of of Texas and then the
real tough one was Fox News amplifying
it every night and this was documented
by two groups Media Matters uh and and a
research group out of uh Switzerland you
know the nighttime Fox News Anor every
night falsely discredited the
effectiveness and safety of vaccines
they filled their broadcast with
antivaccine content and so what happened
was if you were going down that rabbit
hole watching Fox News every night and
everything else you started to believe
that the vaccines either didn't work or
weren't safe and you didn't get
vaccinated and and so many Americans
paid for that with their lives and it's
not you know Neil it's not that we
really care right about people's
political views that's your right as an
American I should speak for you but I'm
guessing you probably of course but but
how do you
uncouple the anti- signs from it I mean
I don't care about your political views
I mean you know whatever they are that's
your right but but how do you say don't
buy into this one because it's going to
kill you but what about what about as we
showed some footage in this film a shot
in the arm of anti-mask movements back
in the 1918 pandemic the flu pandemic so
it seems like being anti-mask was not
just a modern idea or modern concept I
think that's right I think this if you
look back in us his American history
this concept of Health Freedom goes back
to the time of Benjamin Rush you know
the the the founder of so many medical
Societies in Philadelphia and you me you
mentioned in your book dror that he
actually with there's some evidence that
he tried to have something written into
the Constitution about this that's right
that's right and it goes back to the
whole botanical movement um Paul just
showing off that he read your whole book
he I just read the one page and I happen
to get lucky I got well well I'm
grateful as someone who's been accused
of writing forgotten books by anyone who
comes up to me says I read your book he
was sitting quiet they have my attention
waiting for the queue to mention that
one content from the one page you're
such a oh my God I cannot believe that I
work with you so yes I think that that's
so this goes back so there is that
thread throughout history I think the
difference is the amplifying effect of
social media the amplifying or X or
whatever you want to call it and the
amplifying effects on Fox news that
really revved it up and so and people
were monetizing disinformation and I
think that that's what the game changer
isn't it in a way a rigged game for you
for us who are trying to fight this
anti-science cause because it's rigged
in the sense that the only thing you can
prove to make your point is science and
they go well we don't believe in science
so you can't use that one right right
think about right I wish you were that
simple because chronological argument in
debating right it's like there's no s I
know there's but it's even more clever
in sort of a nefarious way than that
because what they'll do is they will
bring in their own experts right these
contrarian experts and and and many of
them are at are at serious medical
schools right even though they're not
specialists in infectious Peter Peter
these are your people yeah exactly these
are your fellow MDS who've been to
medical school they have patients who
call them doctor and so is it a matter
of cleaning up your own house here do s
put some blame back on you it's a good
question because you know they are
professors and at serious places like
Stanford and UCSF and and Hopkins and
and and you know I often ask you my
colleagues why why don't we do anything
to rein this in and they say well you
have academic freedom I said that's true
but you also have something called
professionalism and ethics too and if
it's killing Americans at what point do
you say we shouldn't be doing this and
well you say that in your book too see I
read more than one page that in history
shows that when academics and scientists
tried to stay objective in the face of
fascism and so forth it was too late
once they started to speak up right but
to to an to to Neil's Point these are
your people people I mean politics knows
no bounds right and sometimes politics
and and being with a click that believes
in everything you believe in is more
important than anything that's logical
and you talk about in the book that you
need a clearing house for a people to
defend or an organization to defend
scientists uh in these times where
you're under attack and my suggestion
would be to get all the EX jocks and
high school to defend the scientists
going
forward when the Nerds got beat up in
high the jocks would defend some of the
jocks would defend them this is so this
is what we're seeing now play out in the
House Co subcommittee hearings you know
after I've come out and said look
200,000 Americans needlessly died
because of this disinformation war that
you waged now there's this revisionist
history going on they want to say no no
it was the vaccines that actually killed
Americans absolute nonsense or they want
to say it was the scientists who
invented the virus it's and it's this
rewriting of of history and and not only
targeting the science but targeting the
scientists as well and and it's so
damaging for the for the country my
rebuttal to the pedigreed person on a
YouTube saying that everybody else is
wrong is to
say rebuttal that's not the right word
my response is if a person opens up a
YouTube channel no matter what their
pedigree is and they say the
establishment wants you to think this
but they're all wrong I have the truth
and I'm on your side there is no greater
foundation for suspicion than that
because that is irresistible clickbait
and it means someone is not and then
what people have been doing is giving
main the even the very concept of
mainstream has been thrown into question
by those who are anti- science saying
well the mainstream they all have mono
think and they they don't know the real
this is the real cure for that not what
mainstream my similar rule of thumb is
when someone has to tell you they're a
critical thinker head for the hills
exactly anything but exactly and and and
what's interesting is um you know what
they'll do again very clever in a
nefarious sort of way is they'll say
well we're just asking questions who's
this hotz guy who's being so dogmatic
you know that's not signs for just
asking questions so you have to really
be on your game plus I tell them someone
with a YouTube channel will be more
charismatic than the statistical results
of multiple peer-reviewed studies that
has no face okay and if they have no
accountability to be honest then you
know that that's another handicap and if
you can't condense a 50 page thoughtful
analysis to 180 characters on Twitter no
one's going to read it that's all that's
a problem right so it's like just to be
clear it used to be 140 characters now
it's 280 280 there you go don't don't
reveal how unplugged in you are okay in
front of my audience exactly okay it's
called X by the way Paul not Twitter and
I heard there's this thing called Google
that everybody's really excited
about so so Paul let's get to the
questions sure okay Jump Right In These
are from our fan base and we love them
because they're all like scientifically
literate and they're thoughtful so give
give them to me good afternoon gentlemen
my name is Frank Lewis from Daytona
Beach Florida what is the strangest
conspiracy theories you've come across
boy uh there's so many good ones to pick
from I'll give I'll give you a couple of
my favorite what my absolute favorite
one is claims that I'm I'm not a real
person that I'm actually um Jack Black
being uh being paid by the CIA in a
disguise
so uh the best is when you know they say
the vaccines are magnetizing them and
you know he had one individual you know
testify front of the high legislature
sticking bobby pins and keys on her
forehead and then claiming that they're
sticking to her because she was
magnetized by the vaccines and of course
total theater of the Absurd they fell
right
off again so what's interesting is the
more outrageous the assertion the more
viral it seems to go on on
okay so so Peter because I got to deal
with people who think Earth is flat
that's a whole other thing and but at
least they don't well I was gonna say
Well they're not gonna kill anyone
saying except there was a guy who put
himself in his own a rocket of his own
design to go up high enough to show that
Earth was flat and the rocket misfired
and he died okay and by rocket he meets
a washing machine with wings that's what
he meets so there's at least one
fatality from that movement but okay so
go on Paul give me another uh Matt from
La greetings uh all of course it's uh
super important to fight anti-science
efforts but there must also be some room
within science for ideas that come from
non-scientists currently any
non-credited theorist is treated as a
crank no matter how good the idea is
there some way to create a peer-reviewed
pipeline for ideas to come in from other
disciplines o or from non-experts well
we do have you know Neil you've been a
good promoter of this we do have citizen
science right I think you know
scientists are all in in terms of the
the public engagement I I don't think
that that's necessarily true I think we
we do solicit input um but but you know
when you have people that are
weaponizing the science communication
you see that they have an agenda that's
that's something very different yeah I
would add that when people it's one
thing for people to say I saw something
in this map of the Martian surface
that's on a NASA website that no one has
talked about you know this is
crowdsourcing the analysis of of
information and that can have value but
when someone says I think Einstein is
wrong that E equals actually actually
equals MC cubed instead of MC squared um
you know I spent seven years in graduate
school studying all the work that has
come before me to to know what works and
what doesn't and why and so to so to
spend a couple hours on YouTube and come
up with an idea without the homework
behind that it becomes frustrating to we
in the professional Community because
you didn't do your homework all right
and you end up in that
Valley uh what's that called I I
independently discovered this and I
didn't have a name for it what's it
called where you you um the the Dunning
Krueger effect okay which I I described
as knowing enough to think you're right
but knowing not enough to know that
you're wrong okay oh then I re I really
have that I have so I deduced that turns
out that was a well studied phenomenon
and you and you see this a lot with the
some of the lead antivaccine activists
who um really don't understand the
science and you even see it I see it a
lot now with some of the contrarian and
uals or pseudo intellectuals even have
medical degrees if you notice they're
not they don't have any expertise in
infectious diseases virology or vaccine
they usually come from other fields such
as other fields within the medical world
yeah their s their surgeons or their
radiologist or their you know something
else and then they they overreach right
but then their argument will be you all
have group think and I'm coming from the
outside so I have a fresh view that's
very tempting as clickbait for someone
um so so yeah I mean these are these are
persistent challenges here that uh yeah
we're still at it and then when you
start sounding too dogmatic they've even
come up with a new termal maybe you've
heard this as well they call they say
I'm practicing scientism scientism kind
of like a fusion of religion and Science
and it's all Bs but but again it it s it
superficially it sounds but it's hard to
push back on the religion front right I
mean like because then people start
pulling their religious beliefs in
that's a kind of a sacred uh sort of
place to be and it puts the people on
the right side of this argument in a
tougher position I mean Jehovah's
Witnesses right Christian Scientist
Jehovah Witnesses don't believe very
much in modern medicine which is ironic
because they're constantly getting
broken noses by having doors slammed in
their face stop right anybody needs
modern medicine they did those who are
the ones though that are causing the
damage are those that are you know if
you look they're selling their substack
they're selling their nutritional
supplements they have a they have a
pretty lucrative business going or it's
all about political control and that was
all held by uh Senator by Ron Paul's
sort of passing of that legislation as
you point out in the book that opened up
that whole idea the supplements and and
Neil if you read the book you would know
that but anyway uh Cicero artifon I hope
I'm pronouncing that correctly uh from
Toronto Canada how can how can Society
establish rules informed by scientific
evidence while respecting freedom of
speech and avoiding endorsing
scientifically debunked
ideas oh yeah I think I think he that's
probably the single most important
question and I I spend a lot of time in
the book giving one of the longest I
don't know the answer to your question
answers in modern history is how do you
do that balance I think is is really one
of the challenges I mean you know what
how do you regulate Fox News not to
weaponize health and science
communication how do you control Elon
Musk but not inviting all of the all of
the terrible uh people who are causing
causing Health disinformation damage
Peter you and I might be approximately
the same age so we would remember the
Evening News go back many many decades
the 60s and 70s the evening local news
at the end would have a special carve
out where the the editors or the
producers would give an
opinion on some topic of the day and it
would be specially cover that coming up
we will have an opinion okay and then
that that there would be a commercial
break we'd come we now offer an opinion
and for two minutes they would endorse a
candidate or they would give an opinion
on something now of course you don't see
that firewall between the delivery of
news and the delivery of opinion what I
thought to myself one way to Shore that
up in Fox News or other platforms that
similarly blend their opinion with with
reported news MSNBC does that as well is
if they just had a flashing thing at the
top news and then opinion okay so at any
given instant you would know whether
they would just giveing opinion about I
would I would actually try to do that
when I was on back when I was in the
cable news channels a lot during the
pandemic I would say okay here's what we
know and here's my opinion uh and I and
people like that I mean people you know
really appreciated that I thought okay
so more of that on all fronts would work
yes but on the other hand doing it that
way apparently is not good for TV
ratings or for followers on on Twitter
so right and you would think you would
know that Jack Black you would think you
would know that given that you're in the
entertainment business that Jack Black
would know I should have gotten best
supporting actor on on for Orange County
I'ma no no he should have gotten best I
thought you were brilliant when I when I
found out that I was going to call this
show the first thing I said to my wife
is I'm gonna be on with the guy from
Jumanji that's what I
said and turns out I was
right uh this is Paula PVA uh from
Slovakia my family Embraces conspiracy
theories that's going to be a fun
Thanksgiving um including I don't think
they have that in in where she's from I
know just play along
including my family Embraces conspiracy
theories including concerns about 5G and
microchips and vaccines uh my mom even
got anxious during my recent covid
vaccine uh as an aspiring scientist that
saddens and frustrates me how can I
discuss vaccines uh or any uh scientific
topic with them without causing
immediate argument yeah Peter what do
you do with Thanksgiving dinner when
relatives come
over what's your tactic well it's it's
gotten it's called a bottle of wine
bottle of
wine I mean I mean it's it's gotten more
difficult you know in the past you know
you could talk to a parent you know who
was reluctant about vaccinating their
kid and and say look here's what measles
does here's what prosus does this is why
it's a leading killer of children glor
and here's how the vaccines work and
nine times out of 10 they would agree to
vaccinate their child now it's far more
difficult because they've tied their
political allegiance or their identity
to not getting a vaccine and so how do
you it's not enough simply to provide
accurate information you have to do that
of course but it's not sufficient so it
means trying to really get them to go
communicate values to them try to and
first of all the first thing I Al also
say is remember these individuals are
victims they are victims of a predatory
well organized well- financed
disinformation campaign that's
politically and financially motivated
and and and that helps too that because
otherwise you can get so frustrated and
angry and so you have to look upon them
oftentimes with with sympathy you know I
one of the analogies that I use I not
long ago I gave um medical Grand rounds
at University of Texas Tyler which is a
very conservative area of East Texas
where a lot of um there's a lot of
antivaccine
sentiments and you know everyone you
talked to when I was there has lost the
loved one because they refused the covid
vaccine and these were you know these
are Extraordinary People I though two
weeks later I gave Grand rounds at
Stanford Medical School and I said look
my had card broken now cuz I had a flat
tire and you gave me the choice of my
car breaking out of Palo Alto California
or Tyler Texas I'd pick Tyler every time
because in Tyler everybody be fighting
over who's going to help you change your
tire right I mean see there are
extraordinary people who are are being
victimized or targeted by these
predators and isn't there a subspecies
of Rose called the Tyler Rose am I
remembering this correctly somewhere
Texas there's a tin a small version of a
rose I think it was in Tyler Texas well
you spent time in Texas now I did yeah I
met my wife in Texas yeah yeah isn't
there something deeper that has to be
addressed which is it just feels to me
like whether it's the issue of guns or
abortion or vaccines or whatever
something happened and maybe it was
always there in our society where people
just needed to find something to band
together with other like Minds
regardless of the logic of what they
believe or why they believe it these are
tribal forces and if you don't address
that none of this will ever really go
away it'll be okay today today we're
talking about science but then you know
in in in 10 in 10 months we'll be
talking about some other sort of uh
manipulation of facts and so forth just
to continue to satiate those feelings so
how do you get to that the way I do it
and maybe this is not right but rather
than do that Which is far more daunting
I would basically I say look you know if
you want to believe your Q andon
theories and all this other kind of
craziness again your business but here's
but don't adopt this one somehow we've
got to uncouple Chisel away science
because of the immediate health impact
in the
urgency I'm not sure that's necessarily
the right approach maybe yours makes
makes more sense it sounds like you're
taking it sounds like you're taking the
Lazy Man's approach but good for you you
know that's that's what you want to do
and let Society destroy itself Society
figure it out you know well you're Jack
Black what do you care you have another
movie coming out uh all right we want to
move on another one okay here we go this
is Jarrett rice hello brainiacs you
attribute the internet to a rise in
anti-scientific beliefs or do you think
it has just exposed a percentage of
people that have always felt this
way I think it's I you I first of all I
don't blame only the internet right Fox
News is not a product of of the internet
the the margerie Taylor green calling
people like me medical Brown Shirts is
not an internet um Jim Jordan
weaponizing Health and Science
communication so it and and so people
you know quickly want to jump you know
on on Twitter or X and blame Elon Musk
and and sure he's not helping but that's
only one piece of this the
ecosystem is uh much broader than than
simply social media and the internet and
that's what makes it so daunting is that
it is pervasive now and and uh impact it
affects every aspect of society
anti-science is its own uh is its own
Empire its own ecosystem it's its own
virus even though it started in the
United States I think and I make the
case it started in Texas it's now we're
seeing it move up into Canada with the
freedom with the freedom convoys it's in
Central Europe and now you're starting
to see it contaminate low and middle
inome countries in places that we
haven't seen it yeah so I would say
while the internet didn't created the
internet can magnify yeah what's out
there and but also in there was a day
where you'd have a crazy idea and you
were pretty sure you were correct but
you were alone and now you search on
that crazy idea and every other person
in the world with that crazy idea shows
up and you get get on their chat group
and you and this validates your ideas
when you have it changes the way you
know our communities have changed I Neil
my dad's from the Bronx also went to
dwood Clinton High School and uh that's
across the park from the Bronx High
School of Science yeah theyd always beat
up our our people for their lunch money
just so you know not me but others lunch
money did City College the whole New
York thing and but you know back then
you know you you went to service clubs
at night you went to kan's club or or
rotary or you club and um and if
somebody had a Nutty idea he had three
friends sitting around drinking coffee
or having a beard saying this guy you're
what are you talking about that makes
but you don't have that immediate
feedback anymore so we're not go bowling
together we had a guy like that in our
neighborhood we called him crazy Jack
and he had these theories and it was the
only guy and he just walked around the
neighborhood and he would like
pontificate and everything that's just
crazy Jack now crazy Jack's on the
internet find who's found 23,000 friends
right crazy Jack is now a social media
influencer with a deal with a six-figure
deal with Armani yeah exactly so I have
the official website for shot in thee
it's shot inthe arm movie.com and you
can learn all about it and like I said
our esteemed guest today is is
importantly featured in that film with
regard to his lifetime work on vaccines
as well as um opening up his own family
situation with regard to your daughter
Rachel and uh you said something very
important there Peter that I I don't
think can be overemphasized could you
comment for us the way you did in Shan
of the arm the movie your concern where
people have demonized autism where
autism is sort of has is a natural part
of people's existence and they become
Paras because of what others have said
and done about it could you just
encapsulate that way better than I just
did for me yeah I mean it's it's the way
the antivaccine groups frame people um
uh with autism um as though you're
exactly right as though there are lepers
in the community that you know we need
to be e extricated and and you know it's
extremely offensive particularly those
who are um helping to educate people on
this concept of uh neurodiversity and
you know people who have you know very
productive and interesting lives and
even though they don't always think
think and speak the same way um that
that we do and and so that's that's
extremely hurtful as as as well and um
uh and this kind of gets back to some
very Twisted ideas that come out of the
health and wellness industry and um uh
about what health and wellness is all
about it's a very restricted Paradigm
that um unfortunately is doesn't help
anybody all right thanks for mentioning
that Paul we have time for one or two
more questions what do you have sure
here we go um Jason uh dorin Doren uh
are you ever tempted to just give up
explaining science to people who just
don't want to hear
it well it's kind of become let's re ask
that Peter what would it take to have
you give
up what would what would it take for you
to open a lemonade stand and just say
you're done with all of this well they
tried to create this fund for me to
so-called debate Robert F Kennedy Jr
which I refus to do um so H they uh you
know the I don't know what the final
dollar amount got to be what are you
hiding what are you afraid of of him
right you know we can have a whole
discussion about that but but the point
is I even though it gets scary at times
especially when you have to have a uh
the Houston Police Department parked out
in front of your house you know guard
guarding the house and you have to have
the FBI called in because of threats
it's it's not fun but on the other hand
I do find it meaningful and and I think
the threat to the our system of vaccines
and vaccinations both in the US and
globally is so profound that now calling
myself a vaccine scientist yes it's
great I'm making vaccines for the world
Co and hook War vaccines Etc but now
part of the deal is you have to defend
vaccines and even though it's it's
unpleasant at times it's it I do find it
meaningful and and and during the day
you know talking to amazing people like
you it's you know you're in the mix
you're feeling great it's although at
night it gets you start waking up in the
middle of the night it does get pretty
scary you know with with all of the with
all of the online and inperson stock
online threats and inperson stalkings
hey there's always having a tire
business where you just clean up tires
and in different lots and you just do
that and and I promise you it'll do a
lot of good exactly there some have a
paper it just came out in the New
England Journal of Medicine about yellow
fever returning to Texas in the Gulf
Coast so it's a feel-good story okay
good um well one more question time for
one more tasos surus uh a Greek here he
says uh uh can each of you tell which
anti-science movement is most shocking
to you regarding how far from the truth
and atrocious it is a great candidate
for me is the Flat Earth
movement yeah flat flat Earth is a good
one um I I would say the um the
antivaccine conspiracies are perhaps the
most damaging because there it's
depriving people of essential Public
Health interventions and so that's so
when the weaponization actually affects
human life that to me is when it becomes
more than just a curiosity and and
actually dangerous and again it's not
only targeting the science it's
targeting the scientists portraying us
as Public Enemies or enemies of the
state I mean this is what Stalin did in
the 1930s right to
uh you know he replaced the velan genos
vof with lysenko uh and destroyed the
Russian wheat crop and millions died and
and this is what's happening again just
to be clear so lenko for those who who
missed that chapter in their world
history um lenko had a
discredited understanding of
genetics but that that discredited
understanding matched the political
philosophies of the leaders and so it
was cherry-picked for that reason not
for whether or not it was true and it
had disastrous consequences on the on
the on the um the crops and the
populations that it could support at the
time million I think Millions died is
that right that's right so and and it's
happening again and and I worry that
it's affecting our whole scientific
infrastructure as as I sometimes say you
know we're a nation of great research
universities and institutions Neil you
you studied at Harvard in Columbia I
started studied at Yale and Cornell and
and Rockefeller and and this is this
built our nation We're a nation of
research institutions and universities
it gave us the Manhattan Project and it
gave us Silicon Valley and and in NASA
and and by trying to tear it down I
think it makes us much weak weaker as a
country and so I do worry it's the
long-term consequ you have a really
great term for this from your podcast
it's called the upside down world of
authoritarianism yeah very very much so
those trying to save our lives become uh
the ones you're supposed to eliminate
and uh it goes back in history as you
point you do a great job in the book of
sort of tracing it back you there's a
lot of that I did not realize but you
see it which scared me because
it's 300 years it is doesn't I don't
think it ever goes away right this just
this through line continues it's always
a fight it's always going to be this
fight well and this is why you know Paul
and Neil what you're doing is so
important right I mean anything that
gets people interested in science and
helps people understand science um this
is there's there's never been a more
important time for what you're doing I
think it's more of what I'm doing not so
much what he does but
more yeah Paul is by far way yeah right
EX I had to look up so many words
because of this interview I got a
headache thanks a lot doc no well let me
try to leave this on a positive note
rather than the helpless note that that
that has drenched us throughout this
conversation we were spoke just a moment
ago about how exasperating it can be
when I when I hit that wall I think to
myself the lines from this the musical
the Broadway musical man of lamancha
there's a song in there that we all know
and we've heard it but I don't know how
much you've carefully listened to the
words the the title of the song is to
dream The Impossible
Dream and we all know the song well
where does it come from well donot man
lancha donot is from lancha and he's
tilting at windmills right he wants to
have this jousting contest with the
windmill which doesn't make any sense
like why would you do that and if you
did do it why do you think you win right
so it's the
weird quest to accomplish something
that's not only not realistic but
probably impossible to dream The
Impossible Dream if you look at the
lines of that they're I reference those
lines when I wake up in the morning when
I otherwise would feel hopeless and my
favorite one is to March into hell with
a Heavenly
cause and I
say that's what we got to do
and I just want to say for everybody
watching I think we're all concerned
that he was actually going to start
singing and that was going to be wow
that would have been a terrible way to
end this uh when I feel Hopeless by the
way I think of the lyrics from SpongeBob
SquarePants song that just gets me
focused and ready to go but Neil I think
you know and Paul you bring up good
points in the sense that not so much
SpongeBob which much I like
SpongeBob but the idea is that one of
the reasons that we became scientists
right is we wanted to do big things
right we wanted to make the world a
better place and and even though most
scientists don't speak about humanity
and humanitarian goals I think that's
true for most scientists even though if
they don't articulate that and and we
have to get people to remember this and
the other reason why what you do is so
important is being able to see a face to
the scientists and and I think you know
part of that has been the problem of our
profession we're so inward-looking yeah
we're so focused you know in my case on
our grants and papers and lab meetings
that we don't think about public
engagement as being important and so
we've become invisible to the American
people and and that's created a vacuum
and in this vacuum you have all these
anti-science movements that are that
want to tell the American people what
we're all about which is nothing even
close to
reality whoa there it is right there
Peter your books we're going to be
looking for them apparently Paul's
already read them all but it's I'll I'll
explain him to you Neil
later forgotten people forgotten
diseases the neglected tropical diseases
and their impact on global health and
development you got vaccines did not
cause Rachel's autism your daughter and
more recently the deadly rise of
anti-science a scientist warning Peter
hotz has been a delight to host you for
this I'd seen you for so many Clips on
shot in the arm movie a delight to
actually speak to you in person so
thanks for being on Star Talk thanks Dan
I've admired your work for years it's a
thrill for me to be able to be on this
podcast excellent thank you thank you
Paul always good to have you man always
fun and uh great to meet you real honor
to meet you Doctor all right this has
been Star Talk Cosmic queries Edition
all about basically Public Health with
our featured guest Dr Peter hotz Neil
degrass Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist as always I bid you to
keep looking
[Music]
up